good morning um we'll be opening the
work session for the subcommittee on the
bail rision bills um if you could join
me for the Pledge of Allegiance before
we
begin i' the flag of the United States
America and to the rep for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with liy
and
Justice thank
you as I said yesterday we're going to
today we're going to be working on the
list of crimes that has been proposed to
be non PR
bailable um specifically SP
252 I believe the other Senate Bill
deals with the same thing but we'll look
minute so what we're going to do is
we're going to go down the list um as a
committee and I'm going to open it up
for discussion on each of these crimes
and everyone please feel free to weigh
in on whether you think this should or
should not be eligible for PR
bail before I do though I would like to
hear from
um the Manchester police chief who might
help us in our
deliberations as we um discuss these
so
Chief someone's going to give you a copy
of that bill that has I have it in front
of me oh you have it okay thank you
you yeah I don't want to get into um I
think I've been here before chairman uh
in offer Dan doen off other other datter
and um I think what I would say is you
know law enforcement but more
importantly uh the communities at large
across the state of New Hampshire um
something needs to flex U something
needs to change I'm not a proponent of
putting everybody into jail
unnecessarily I don't think that's the
right method um but I will tell you that
um I'll give you one quick statistic
from May of 2022 to August of this year
the Manchester police department has
made just under 5,800 arrests of those
arrests 1,500 just over 1500 had active
bail conditions at the time of the
arrest now those could have been bail
conditions from anywhere across the
state um what the data needs to be next
dive in on the data needs to be how many
of those people were uh previously
arrested for a violent offense perhaps
the ones that El listed in this bill and
how many reoffended with the violent
offense um so I think we owe that to
this committee we owe that to um at
least from the Manchester side to
provide that to you so that that data is
being put together now because I think
that will offer a little bit more
perspective um but again we're talking
about the quality of life across the
state of New Hampshire I think it's no
secret in Manchester that it's um it's
deteriorated um because a lot of people
that continue to reoffend and reoffend
and reoffend um where these people were
out on bail what we started doing why
the data starts in that a um May of last
year is when we arrest people we now
have a spot on our arrest report are you
currently out on bail so the individual
is self-reporting and I I think this
committee's talked about before kind of
synchronizing that system across the
state so that we know where somebody
actually is out on bail um and I think
that's been brought up before I think
that would be very helpful to law
enforcement I think it would be very
helpful to the courts um so that we have
a true understanding of where somebody
is out on bail when they reoffend so we
can notify that agency um so they can
take the appropriate steps if they
choose to do so um but again you know
get to the ground truth ladies and
gentlemen um I'm out there my men and
women are out there every day dealing
with people who have reoffended and
reoffended um it's it's quite frankly
it's getting old for my police office
it's getting old for the community that
I that I serve in and a lot of these
people that are reoffending will will
tell you if you get out and have
conversations with them that they're not
getting help for their substance abuse
they're not getting help for their
mental health and they're not getting
help towards employment um all things
that are real and that law enforcement
doesn't turn a blind eye to we fully
understand the substance abuse issue
trust me we fully understand the mental
health issue but these people will tell
you that they're not getting the help
they need and they being in jail is at
least a start on a path to getting well
hopefully um sure there's Street
Outreach that takes place there's many
nonprofits out there doing work but when
people are dealing with mental health
and substance abuse then you're you know
lack of a better ter lack of a better
term you're turning and burning them out
of a police department or out of a out
of a court on some type of low bail or
PR bail for multiple re offenses um that
they're not going to they're not going
to be in position to get themselves help
and really at the end of the day I think
that's what we all want is to help
people but the current system frankly is
not designed it's not getting the people
the help that they need um I'll give you
I'll take any questions you may have but
I think this bill that's in front of you
certainly these are egregious offenses
that people should at least be held for
a short period of time until they can
get in front of a judge and let the
judge make the decision
um I think sometimes um you know we ask
our bail Commissioners to do a lot um
they're great in the city of Manchester
I can tell you that but I'll go a little
step further they need to get paid all
right they need to get paid ladies and
gentlemen um whatever that mechanism is
when I'm calling these people in at 2
3:00 in the morning Christmas morning
every holiday you can think of every
inconvenient time and then not being
compensated um this doesn't seem like
the American way to me so I'll end with
that
thank you Chief uh I I have a few
questions it seems to me um back in the
day if you were
arrested no one from a police department
would call a bail commissioner unless
you had the bail money present um would
that in your mind if if if regardless of
you end up on PR bail or not you had to
come up with the $40 to pay the bail
commissioner for that service do you
think that that would change things in
I'm sorry thank you um I think there
probably be some legalities around that
I think that's a dangerous road to go
down that hey if you don't have 40 bucks
on you we're not going to allow you to
see a bail commission there's probably
some constitutionality issues there I'm
sure my friends in the in the room would
uh probably agree um
so yeah did that maybe happen in the
past I'm not sure I don't have any
experience with that but yeah if so if
the def
doesn't have $40 then generally in the
past they would go to court and some
judges at Manchester District Court
would make arrangements for them to you
know come up with the $40 um but I think
the vast majority of time you know they
don't present the 40 at the time of bail
bail commissioner gives them an envelope
hey please pay me please pay me um as a
baill commission in the room he can
probably give the percentage of the time
he receives payment back probably pretty
low yeah we heard testimony in that
yesterday and it it was extremely low
right um with regard to the reoffending
um this list of crimes that we're
looking
at could you tell us what the majority
or category of the crimes that these
folks keep getting picked up on I'm
assuming it's not this list of of very
dangerous uh violent crimes yeah well I
tell you the city of Manchester um you
know homicides are what they right I
mean why we know what our homicide rate
is but obvious I think that's a
no-brainer um you have first degree
assault second degree assault uh
domestic violence afsa um FSA um
kidnappings um we we do get a rash of
those um you know stalking human
trafficking I mean all of these are
applicable in the city of Manchester um
and probably applicable across the state
unfortunately I just have a greater
volume of them um so yeah I think this
is this is is a start and it's
appropriate start but I think we need to
keep having the conversation about these
people that are continuing to
reoffend definitely that are not on this
list my question I guess was what I'm
trying to get is are are you seeing bail
Commissioners releasing people on these
crimes um yes I am
okay does anyone else have any questions
for the
chief um yes uh representative follow up
to the question that chairman Roy just
asked how many approximately would you
say are violent crimes that are being
led out by Bell Commissioners I think
that's going to be the next dive into
the data that we would owe this
committee um from the Manchester side um
so I had somebody sted working on that
this morning um and we won't take long
to to glean that data but I don't want
to give you an answer that may be wrong
so we will get that back I commit to get
yes um
so one of the things that you you said
is being in jail uh is at least a start
and one of the things I think that we've
heard consistently in this committee uh
from folks who maintain and manage the
county jails is essentially how under
resource and under staff they are when
it comes to actually dealing with mental
health and substance abuse so um I I'm
I'm just wondering um what kind of a
start is Jail uh in in your mind uh for
somebody who is
rearrested um and may be rearrested for
similar crimes over and over again um
what kind of a start does it provide it
could be part of their plea agreement
sir that um hey you you've agreed to
plead to this particular crime for you
know x amount of time in in the county
facility and part of your conditions are
that you enroll in substance abuse that
you get Mount to health counseling um
some you know some communitybased
corrections if you will and that would
then to effectively monitor these people
upon release um so there's some type of
accountability or at least checks and
balance because quite frankly sir what
happens is people are released from jail
and in my city there you know the door
opens on Willow Street and and out they
go and and that's not really fair to the
individual um because a lot of these
people do want help um but when the when
to your point resources are limited um
perhaps Staffing is we all have staffing
issues in every Walk of Life right now
right so I don't really accept that we
got to find a way just like I have to
find a way every day um but just to open
the door and release these people with
no real connections or no hey who do I
contact who do I reach out to who's
going to check on me um we're we're
failing them as well um because again a
lot of them them want to get better and
I believe like many that the criminal
justice system has a role in that other
than simply arresting people and putting
them in jail um what you know I'm sure
the correction folks can come in here
and speak to the programs that they
offer and how to properly connect with
these people and how to properly track
them so they're on a path to being well
and and decreasing the Harms in our
you representative gath
I don't know if this is a question for
you but you mentioned that um I guess
it's not then you mentioned you
mentioned that they would uh if they
have mental officials or drug abuse you
know they sort of want to be in jail and
this is their starting point I might
understand that if it's a issue with
drugs but with mental health I'm not
understanding why that unless the jail
is given meds because if they're just
sitting in jail because we literally
went to a hearing and listened to a man
asked to go to the mental health
facility and unfortunately could not be
released to do that so I'm just yeah I
guess that specific case but what I will
tell you representative is um people
that are struggling with mental health
um and say if they're homeless or say if
they're vast majority of time substance
abuse is on board as well unfortunately
um and when they're um released into the
community without any type of connection
to back to the resources that are
available these people vanish or they go
to places that they're hard they're hard
to find and hard to connect them with
those resources because the greater
Mental Health Center of Manchester
perhaps had contact with them
reestablished that relationship upon
arrest or upon being a facility and then
when they're released it's hard to
maintain that connection because they go
back into wherever they came from
whether it's in the woods or at a
homeless camp or again I'm not so we're
sensitive to that but trying to keep
these people connected with the services
that are available is the challenge it's
very difficult for every every
discipline and I would imagine if
somebody's in a jail and they need to
get into some type of mental health
counseling I I know that jails make
those arrangements to do
so and chief um if I could what type of
services or liaison do you have with
mental health at your station do you
have a a worker or anyone like that
who's there um for example during the
evenings when you're busiest yeah the
mobile crisis unit that's our main
conduit um between police department and
the Mental Health Center Greater
Manchester so it could be 2 in the
morning that we have somebody in Mental
Health crisis the mobile crisis team
will respond with a clinician and peerto
peer um and hey oh this hey this
person's already a client let's get them
reconnected or this person's not a
client let's start getting him or her
connected the best way that we
can is that a Manchester funded
organization that's a mobile crisis
teams are across the state so it's
funded by the Department of Health and
Human Services across the state the
funding I would I or controlled or
organized by yes
yeah then they're they're they're tapped
out they're going out of catchman areas
and they're they're busy
yeah perpendicular to what chairman Roy
just asked are there what pre- trial
Services exist in the jail uh right now
for people who are incarcerated that for
the Hillsboro County it's called the ACT
program I can send you the literature on
that sir I can send it to this committee
um and that's a superintendent castano
who came from bar County um to Hillsboro
County was lacking pre-trial services at
Hillsboro County House of Correction um
were essentially non-existent and
superintendent castano recognized that
having come from Mar County and he's
trying to get that get that right um
back to my point about every facet of
the Criminal Justice System having a
role in trying to do what we can for
these people because again I'm not a
proponent of just putting people in jail
and locking the door and tell them to
have a good day all right those I don't
think you're going to find any police
mentality well I would hope me phrase it
that way go ahead thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I want
to go I want to go back to one of your
very first original statements when you
had given us the number of arrests and
then how many of those arrests were uh
people that had bail conditions that
that appeared to have been
broken then you went to the people that
were looking for help right Looking For
assistance with the mental health or the
the substance abuse right do you know
out of those people the 1500 that you
mentioned how many of those or in
opinion was receiving the treatment part
of the conditions that were given and if
one they just didn't follow through with
that themselves or was it a lack of not
being able to provide what was ordered a
great question I don't have that data
that's an excellent question um I would
think there's a a decent majority of
those people um
you know again there's a lot of
nonprofits and Outreach you know doing
doing great work and trying to do more
great work um but there's also a
population of those people that um no
matter what you offer them um in their
mind they're not at Rock Bottom yet um
so they're going to refuse the vast
majority of people that we deal with
every day on our Outreach that the
police department does along with the
fire department
um a good majority of those people will
refuse your services you know right to
your face um okay but does that mean we
give up on them no um but how long they
are they going to be allowed to remain
in the community to cause further harm
um to businesses and and innocent people
where we eventually we got to draw a
line and you got to you know these
people got to get help they're going to
continue to cause harm and that's the
balance right that's that's I think
that's the challenge may I have follow
up so ju just for clarification
you're you're not aware if if that was
part of their part of the bill
conditions was just was to actually
receive this treatment you no but one
one standard Bill condition for
everybody is not to use illegal drugs or
excessive alcohol right so we know that
they've all that's a standard bail
condition
so you know okay a lot of them are
violating that right out of the gate now
what they're head condition or part of
their agreement to to enroll in some
type of program and then could be drug
court right MH um drug court has its
successes but there are some people that
I reoffend while in drug court and three
or four or five times over um
so I I would I would imagine to I would
hope that the courts would have that
information they could provide that to
you yeah thank you um Chief I if if
there were a a component that had
mandatory inhouse treatment as a
diversion to some of these people is are
you aware of even a place that could
handle the number of people that that
you see day in and day out in this state
in my County uh Hillsboro County I mean
I know that the population at the County
facility is not what it what it was preo
uh their numbers are down substantially
but I don't want to speak to their
population but um
I know they can take in more people um
and perhaps start connecting more people
with more services because again what's
happening right now on the streets is
not
working and that's that's just a m
matter of general practice and living it
and seeing it every day of my life
representative Stone thank you Mr
chairman chief from your experience
under the current bail system that we're
utilizing what's the impact on the
victims of some of these yeah a great
Point yeah especially domestic violence
victims or any victim right a victim is
a victim um and now those are the people
that we hear from quite a bit
representative of what do you mean he or
she got released you know especially if
it was a some of these crimes that you
listed in this bill involving Firearms
or or stabbings um again I don't want to
give you anecdotes but you know last
week had a riot of 10 people that
arrested um felony Riot first deegree
assault um hope you know thankfully the
the main aggressive was hell
um so that's good but yeah we hear from
victims all the time um and I'll be
frank with you what I'm telling them now
is to engage with your elected officials
um and be vocal and speak to the people
that you're sending up to conquet on
your behalf um to to do the state's
business um because I can only do as
much as I can do the courts can do what
they can do but again I'm not looking
for overwhelming change I'm looking for
this is a good start this is this is
kind of heading us back in the right
direction and amongst all the other
things that a lot of other agencies are
doing to help people follow up real
quick followup Chief since 2018 in the
implementation of the new baill system
do you feel that law enforcement hands
been
tied tied no because I we still have the
ability to enforce the laws right that
are on the books and we're doing that um
I think what you're seeing is um you
know we operate within the you know the
left and right limits of the of the
state laws what you're seeing is a
massive drain on the people that put on
this uniform um yes we signed up to do
this job but when you're dealing with
the same people over and over and over
it's hurting law enforcement it's
hurting you if you don't see what if you
don't think when people consider being a
law enforcement officer especially this
this generation now they do their
homework a lot more than perhaps I did
when I got on the job um they're paying
attention they're paying attention to
what's going on in the state and what's
the what's the temperature and and you
know what are criminal behaviors what
are they getting away with or you know
how much are they being held accountable
um so I think really there's a sense of
especially in my community I 100%
confident saying it that the temperature
in Manchester is that people are not
being held accountable for their
criminal Behavior and that's the
reality Chief a lot of what we hear in
the public hears is from the media um
and sometimes it's not exactly accurate
uh could you help there was a a case
that we saw just a few weeks ago where
there were two brothers arrested I
believe it was for a shooting in
Manchester and the judge let him go and
everybody was like how is that possible
could you give us a little background if
you could on that case it's an open
investigation so I that would be
slippery for me to to get into that um
but we do have people that have
committed gun violence who have been um
no granted a superior court judge May
set a cash bill that the person is able
to meet okay then you know yeah but um
there have been cases where people have
committed violent offenses and have been
um have been released on extremely low
bail or in some instances uh PR bail so
in in your opinion if the district
attorney had the ability to appeal which
they currently do but they don't appear
to take advantage of it very often
because the offender is already gone at
the door I think um Mr Shear brought
this up before I do agree with him in
terms of revoking people's bail um yes
that happens at the district court level
um and but at the superior court level
um at least in Hillsboro County the
county attorney's office or an assistant
County attorney has to file the motion
to violate the person's bail um so yes
we provide them with the report and the
information and say Hey you know Alan
aldenberg was out on bail out of
Superior Court he reoffended on a
violent offense you know hey filed the
motion um I think that's a great
question for the County attorneys in
those cases how many times are they
exercising what's currently available to
them yeah um to go ahead and do that um
I'll be frank I mean I'll had a
conversation with an assistant County
attorney one of my people did a couple
weeks ago and he was not even
aware that he could appear he could do
that right so that's concerning yeah all
right um and I I think that's probably
Mr shear and I agree maybe we is he
nodding his head I don't know um well
what I was getting at is also what
if if a judge says okay I'm going to let
someone go on one of these crimes on PR
or extremely low
bail it because with the the change from
felonies first everything's going to end
up back in the district court originally
sure is and if the district court just
says okay
PR and the district attorney had the
ability to appeal to the superior court
and as part of that the person would be
held until the
appeal versus just walking out of the
district court with that do you think be
help I I mean once that case is you know
once felon's first and goes in effect
goes back to district court and you have
that probable cause hearing at district
court and that the judge find probable
cause the case will be bound over to
Superior Court um so the whole case goes
there um you
know I would I would defer an attorney
on that if they would then want to you
know argue for a bail hearing um but
usually requests for bail hearings come
from defense counsel um to have the
baill changed okay all right yeah the
Felon first thing is going to be
interesting that's a whole another topic
yeah one one thing at a time any further
questions represent wheeler first of all
Chief aldenberg thank you for your time
and your testimony um can you ensure
that the data that you compile around
people getting re arrested uh
distinguishes between judges who have
released them and the bail Commissioners
who have released them I can certainly
do my best thank you um again I think I
think the tracking system at the courts
needs to be needs to be enhanced I think
we try that last year I believe or um
because that would really so that we're
all on the same page on one system I
know it's going to take a while to to
get that to where it needs to be but
then that would provide you with you
would be able to get that in in real
time I would believe in in the future
because those are those are those are
great questions absolutely Y and
thankfully chair I would want to know it
too yeah thankfully chairman Roy is
really passionate about upgrading the
system so hopefully we'll get that done
and I would assume the information that
you have is going to be pre-arranging
anyway you are you tracking these cases
all through all through the no all the
stuff is uh is pre-arraignment
yeah I'm pretty confident I'm very
confident in our our system and our
numbers yeah thank you Chief so I think
what I owe this committee at some point
Mr chairman is um the deeper dive on
those 1500 I mentioned um if you would
like that absolutely I mean that's a
startling number of 1500 out of 58 that
are already on bail um is is Germain
exactly to what we're here for so yes
but I think you need to know how many
were violent and non-violent offenses
yeah and we'll also send this Comm the
committee that um program that's
currently taking place at the Hillsboro
County House of Correction so you can
have that information as well thank you
thank for your time ladies and gentlemen
thank you Chief is there anyone else
here from the law enforcement community
testify
no okay um at this point um I'd like to
hear from I think if he's willing uh
since I see him professor Shear would
you like to address the
committee I'd like to get all aspects
and
Views sorry to put you on the spot but I
want to make sure we hear from everybody
fair
enough my students put me on the spot
so
um I'll give my standard disclaimer uh I
I'm a a professor at UNH law I'm also
police elected Police Commissioner in
Portsmouth um my statements uh today and
always are uh mine only they are not
don't exess they don't uh they're not
the opinions of unh law University of
New Hampshire or the Portsmouth police
commission um
so
um
I'm sorry I
was boy that's unusual for
me
um
um a couple preliminary points number
one uh the bail
system has never been designed nor
should be designed to hold people
accountable for their crimes that's what
the subsequent criminal justice system
is about I appreciate uh the immense
difficulties that victims uh of crimes
uh uh suffer uh and how how hard it is
for them in so many different
circumstances but I think uh anyone who
represents to a victim of the crime that
the bail
system will make sure that uh the person
who's alleged to have committed the
crime will hold them accountable it's
it's they're misrepresenting that to a
victim the the criminal legal system as
a whole is designed to hold people
accountable but not the bail system at
the front end and and that uh I
understand people's
frustration uh that uh accountability is
not as doesn't happen as quickly as it
should um in many circumstances but uh
that's not because of problems with the
bail system that's because of problems
with other parts of the Criminal Justice
System uh and uh the resources that are
in place um so uh Point number one point
number two uh I I appreciate Chief
aldenberg comments uh that uh about uh
those uh who are struggling with
substance AB issues or mental health
issues it's really the bail system has
never been designed nor does it
particularly work
well to uh address those issues as a
part of the system you know the bail
system as a constitutional matter has
always been viewed as uh having two
purposes one uh to protect the public uh
from dangerous people uh while a charge
is
pending um and two to make sure they
show up for court a lot of you know
there's an infinite variety of bail
systems across the United States and um
they all you almost all of them try and
do it a different way you know there's
there's
51 uh different bail systems in the
United States the federal system and the
50 states plus there's uh tribal Juris
addtions who have their own system so um
I think there are uh counties in New
Hampshire for example straford County
which has a lot of resources because
they h house and get paid for housing a
lot of federal inmates they have a very
sophisticated uh pre-trial Services
Program where a judge can say well I'm
going to let you out on pale you need to
engage in this system in this way and
that way and those are those tend to be
uh much more
effective uh than counties without uh
formal pre-trial Services um it's it you
know I won't say uh it's I think it's
obvious why um but when when it's a
county that's trying to piece together
ways to deal with those who are mentally
ill or suffer from mental health issues
or substance abuse issues or who are
homeless uh the baell system just
doesn't work well that way and and and I
understand uh the general Public's
concern Police Department's concerns or
what do we do with these people uh I
just we've always struggled you know
I've been at this bail stuff since
2017 and we've always struggled with how
to deal with those societal issues uh um
and how much we really can ask of a bail
system to to deal in you know in an
immediate sense or certainly not a
long-term sense with homelessness with
uh uh those struggling with mental
health issues those with substance abuse
problem I think you know most people who
deal with homelessness know uh and try
and address those issues uh know that um
and all the re Arch says this also that
the most important thing to deal with
with homelessness is finding ways to
House people that's the key uh to
dealing with
homelessness um obviously that doesn't
mean housing them in the jail um but um
so I make those two points in terms of
the specific uh crimes uh I think that
um the list that is in uh what was last
uh session the Susi bill which or that
which has been in the uh in past bills
put forward by uh Senator Bradley too
expansive you know I'm I'm an advocate
of the list only
including uh
felonies um uh I I think that is uh um
that's a better
system um it's it's less inclusive I
think this committee has heard in the
past from the court system when that
list includes
misdemeanors that means the court system
is going to have to deal with in short
term four to 5 th 3 to 4,000 more
hearings and it's a profound resource
drain on the court system that they
won't be able to handle
um so I think including misdemeanor on
that list of crimes is uh is a mistake
and it's a it's a mistake for resource
reasons you know some of the crimes that
particularly when it's a misdemeanor
particularly when it's a person who's
the first time they've committed a
misdemeanor it's very unlikely they're
going to get jail time uh on those
offenses and if they end up at the front
end being held pre-trial they're going
to end up serving time that they
wouldn't serve if they were convicted
and sentenced on the case
um I also am an advocate of finding ways
uh and I I think the concern that uh the
police and Senator Bradley have
expressed that gave rise to that list of
crimes in what's now Senator susi's Bill
before the
committee I think the A system that
solves that problem is one that gets
individuals
uh in front of a judge quicker than the
current system
does um that
way a system that uh uh has those crime
has a list of crimes for which the
person will not see a bail
commissioner um but they will see a and
they they they are held until they see a
judge that's a much more pal mble system
uh to me if they see a judge within 24
hours whereas the way it is now if that
were to pass with that list you know
they if they're arrested on Friday
evening they're not going to see a judge
at the earliest until Monday morning or
if it's a long weekend until Tuesday
morning depending on the court
scheduling so you know I think that's
one of my fundamental problems with
grafting on that list of crimes to a
system as the way in the way it works
now is people sit in jail too long on on
circumstances where they otherwise might
be released waiting to see a judge
because it's on those list of crimes if
we shorten that period of time to 24
hours um then you know uh that list of
crimes uh is uh I think that list of
crimes with only felonies on it I think
that's a palatable uh and manageable
list you know and I have in the ideal
world I have the bail system as I was
design it but you're not here to listen
to me talk about the ideal World
Professor if you could I don't mean
interrupt you but could you tell me
which on the list are misdemeanors um
I'm looking at the list do you have it I
do not have it in front of me from my
memory such as it is I believe Chief Al
is going to give it to you just an
uncharacteristic
uh thank you I will note for the record
Chief halberg said he agreed with me on
something earlier we have that on tape
thank you I appreciate that we'll edit
that please
do
um uh domestic violence some of them are
misdemeanors uh I believe some of the
trafficking in persons can be
misdemeanors uh I uh and I am uncertain
uh as to uh the uh computer pornography
and child exploitation um you know I
I'll be uh
straightforward uh my list would be
homicides first degree assault second
degree assault felony domestic violence
aggravated felonia sexual assault
felonia sexual assault kidnapping felony
stalking stalking is another one that
frequently is misdemeanor uh trafficking
in persons uh felony trafficking in
persons uh manufacturer of child sexual
abuse images uh I I would not put on
this list possession or
distribution uh I think those are less
inherently dangerous in the immediate
sense you know if we release somebody
from on bail on possession of child
sexual abuse images I don't think uh
there's any uh t able enough danger to
other people while that person is out on
bail that said manufacturing child
sexual abuse images certainly is a very
dangerous
crime um and felony computer pornography
and child exploitation so that's the
list that I would recommend to this
committee um I think that uh
uh it would reduce the chance that
people will be held on crimes pre-trial
that they wouldn't get jail time post
Tri uh post disposition of the hearing
post conviction assuming they're
convicted number one and number two it
would reduce the cost uh to the court I
would add uh one more thing there is
some data out there that suggest that in
the research I've done and uh some
testimony I heard from both the court
system and the public defender program
several years ago in a work a study
commit involving the office of Cost
Containment that collects poor people
from collects money from poor people who
are appointed counsel um uh there was
some evidence that somewhere between 25
and
35% of all criminal cases uh in which
council is appointed end up being
dismissed so whatever this list
contains and if it results in people
being held uh
pre-trial there's an uncomfortably large
number of people who are going to be
held for crimes that eventually will get
dismissed or for which they will be
found not guilty so that's another check
on how expensive we want to make this
list uh I appreciate that the
concern should should be with this list
uh in terms of thinking about
dangerousness how dangerous are they
going to be while they're out on bail
until this case is disposed of it's not
a more Cosmic is this person in general
a dangerous person it's while they're
out on ba the point of bail is are they
going to be dangerous to themselves or
others while they're out on bail with
this charge pending um so those are my
my thoughts on uh on this list more than
more than willing to answer
questions thank you um I I've got a
question it's not necessarily pertaining
to the list but it's to the issue of
getting the bill Commissioners paid um
you mentioned the office of Cost
Containment if a if a if a defendant
were released and it were ordered by the
court for him or her to pay the for
$ first before any fines restitution or
anything else would the offs of Cost
Containment be the ones who would go
after them for that or would that be the
court trying to maintain followup that
would be the court the office of Cost
Containment statutorily is set up to
collect money from PE now from people
who have been convicted of crimes for
which they had a lawyer appointed okay
um you know I I have my own concerns
about the office because the true nature
of the office is let's com collect money
from poor people who've been appointed
lawyers because they're poor uh you know
there's a certain measure of
inconsistency with the whole idea behind
the office of cause containment separate
topic not for us to deal with um but
uh
um I think it would be the the
court if they were
ordered by the court
to pay the
$40 it would be up to the court to
enforce in some other in some fashion
whatever they choose uh the payment of
those
$40 you
know I'll just add this uh not intending
to confuse the issue but it will you
know there's an interesting moral
question of if somebody's arrested for a
crime they don't have the $40 they're
order to pay the $40 and the charge
against them is later dismissed or
they're found not guilty you know do we
want the system to still collect the 40
bucks from them they're not the ones who
chose to be arrested and go in front of
the bail commissioner it's an obligation
that it was imposed on them by the fact
that they were
charged involving the charge that would
later go
away um you know there's there's a
inconsistency there that it's a wrinkle
that probably is worthy of attention but
yeah it be the court the short answer
which I usually don't give is yes it
would be up to the court system I I I
might agree if they were found not
guilty um dismissal doesn't by any
stretch mean that they're not guilty and
I think that it's a service that they're
availing themselves up correct me if I'm
wrong but there's no constitutional
right to bail there's only a
constitutional right to not have
excessive bail so if that is correct
they have the option to stay in jail if
they want till the morning if they Avail
themselves of the service service it
seems they should at some point have to
pay for it
um or is that did I just open a large
constitutional can of worms uh there's a
can of worms there and I won't address
the can of worms and we can we can fight
in some other context over with the
meaning of a dismissal you know some
sometimes a dismissal means the
prosecutor looks at the case and says
boy this is so bad a case I'm not going
to trial and risking getting a not
guilty you know that kind of dismissal
is one thing if a dismissal that's a
part of
uh multi-jurisdictional plea bargain
it's a whole another thing so oh let me
add one more thing you
know and I've raised this with some on
the
committee the police have the authority
on misdemeanors and violations to
instead of arresting somebody and going
through the bail commissioner process to
the extent they do with misdemeanors
usually they don't with violations to
summons the person to court rather than
uh to take them through uh the temporary
custody the arrest and um and a bail
commissioner uh you know uh embedding in
in the bail system a uh let's call it a
preference rather than make it mandatory
but a preference in those in
misdemeanors for the police to summons
that person to court rather than having
them have to go through the bail
commissioner process uh might save
everybody time I mean there's some
potential downsides to that but um I um
I throw that out as as a something for
the committee to think
about I worry that would that might end
up though in just a a slew of default
warrants because if someone's uh
homeless I don't know how they would get
their mail but it there is some
something to think about I think in that
yeah you know I I the way I would set it
up is there would be a um uh when they
were summons they would be summoned for
a particular court date the summons
itself which they would be given in hand
the police would have to coordinate with
the court system on this but have a list
of court dates that people could be
summoned to for an arraignment on that
uh on that misdemeanor then again the
police would have an option depending on
the misdemeanor if they wanted to arrest
a person and see a bail commissioner ask
for a a lack of of of uh you know to be
held without bail um you know that
option should be there still thank you
um representative
scitec Mr chairman as I said before I'd
like to testify later but this is a
great opportunity when do I ever get the
chance to add something to Professor
Sher and that's this don't feel the
obligation oh well I understand the
thing is that we will the police police
are aware of what you've said they don't
choose as you said to implement it but
when it does come in why they want a
bail sometimes is to you can't with a
Summons issue bail conditions so that's
why they like the bail process and and I
think um you could amend the current I
think it's
59714 it's 59414 or I can't remember the
exact
RS statute number I think you could
amend that to have with any summons for
misdemeanor uh to a future court date uh
a set of statutory conditions that
accompanied accompanied the summons uh
and
thought welcome to the bail
system uh representative
Muse um yeah first just uh just a
comment uh uh for the chief it would be
enormously helpful if um that uh data
that you're going to provide us actually
would somehow get correlated to the list
of crimes that are in uh s SP2 42 to
whatever extent is possible um that
would really help us see where the the
biggest pain points are areas that maybe
are are are less relevant um uh having
data like that and it's always really
hard for us to get data like that would
be enormously helpful as we uh try
finalize the list um the the other thing
that I wanted to ask you about is I know
one of the problems uh that uh has been
kind of an ongoing issue with bills that
have listed these crimes is either the
written in uh wording that there is a
presumption of dangerousness or the the
fact even when you take the word out
there's a presumption of
dangerousness um does reducing the the
time that somebody can be held without
seeing a judge does that make basically
make that issue go away so if it's less
than 24 hours if it's 24 hours or less
substantially yeah it makes that issue
dissol relatively speaking dissolve um
you know
constitutionally you can probably it's
pretty straightforward that you can hold
someone certainly for at least 2 hours
without having them see a judge um that
uh so yes it does reduce that time so
you know that's a that's an additional
benefit to reducing that time and of
course you know that's a conversation
with I think
as uh chair Roy had expressed you know
that that merits a conversation with the
court system thank you um Professor Shar
just while I have you here one of the
main issues we're going to be addressing
and and this applies to you from a more
you have experience in the research
Department with our courts
recently what do you think the need is
for us to just I mean I know they have
J1 and and some other systems of just
starting from scratch and implementing a
a a broad comprehensive it system that
links the court the police probation
parole everybody real time and finally
get us all where we need to be and would
be able to allow the public to come in
and make request for data that would
actually be accurate without having to
go to every different courthouse in the
State uh as I think as I said before
this Committee in my efforts to
sometimes vain sometimes slightly less
than vain to uh provide you know partial
data to the court best I can given the
difficulty that court system uh provides
in extracting any data from it I think
it's essential for reasons related to
bail and for reasons related to other
parts of the the criminal legal system I
think we you know ever since I uh
started thinking about bail and working
with many legislators and others about
bail uh we always bump up against the
lack of data problem because the court
system had is only a case management
software system it doesn't have a data
collection system and that's a
fundamental problem nor are any of those
nor since they don't have a data
collection system it's not connected to
the to the police um or other
significant the court system the to to
the Daily court system so I I think uh
that's
um That's essential you know uh I I know
Chief allenberg and others are very
aware you know it's discussions we
sometimes have on the Port Smith police
commission that um the communication
problem between the police and the
prosecutors and the courts so that
prosecutors know what's um uh what the
background of the individual that's in
front of them when they are first
dealing with when they're dealing with
that person person at a bail hearing
with which is their first
encounter you know uh the description
that Chief aldenberg gave conversation
with uh an assistant County attorney is
you know
just uh outrageous that they weren't
even aware that they could file a motion
as I understood what he said they
weren't even aware they could file a
motion to revoke
bail yeah it it um I
mean members of this committee have
heard me talk about uh you know the the
statute's fine the bail statute's fine
it's just got to be people got to use it
I mean there's mechanisms for people who
are rearrested after being out on bail
on a misdemeanor or a felony there are
plenty of me mechanisms in the bail
statute as it is for them to be called
to account for being rearrested is just
prosecuted it's not that police's fault
except in those jurisdictions where
there's a police prosecutor it's the
prosecutor's fault they're just not
doing it uh maybe it's a staffing issue
what Chief Al the story Chief aldenberg
told me you know said testified to you
just like that's an education problem um
hopefully it wasn't one of my former
students who said
that
well and I this would be a good time for
me to um say this and um I I want to
make sure that the the members of the
committee and the public we we are not
um we're not blaming any particular
especially you know we're talking a lot
about the courts and it always strikes
me when I watch a state of the union
where the courts have to sit on their
hands whilst somebody berate them
because they are um they're not supposed
to have opinions and they're not
supposed to be defending themselves so I
want to make it clear we're not bashing
the court we're not bashing the
prosecutors we're not bashing anybody um
we're just trying to fix a problem and
um if if a district attorney wasn't
aware of that then um I I I don't I
don't think that it's I'm not going to
Advocate that we make them go to school
again I just hope that they maybe get
wind of it and they realize they can but
right now I'm concerned with this
information system and it seems like
everything we're discussing is
predicated upon someone having the
proper information so a DA who doesn't
know someone's full record or may not
even want to appeal it because it seems
like you know all he's dealing with is a
case in front of him and a a bail
commissioner not being able to see that
someone has a history of defaults can't
make an informed decision um so it seems
like it all is heading back to that
information problem I I I I agree with
you uh representative Roy and you know
uh more broadly but in vain with what
you're saying I mean I uh I've had
concerns about the BL statute being
blamed for all the problems in the
system and and I think uh there's a lot
in there that if used properly it would
be fine that said I think I think the
the chair's goal and this committee's
subcommittee's goal to uh look more
comprehensively at systemic problems is
going to involve you know the court
system putting a little skin in the game
and making some changes prosecutors
doing the same thing the public defender
office in terms of Staff Staffing
putting some skin in the game the police
putting some skin in the game you know I
think everybody's got to be willing if
we want to make this the bail statute
work better um I think uh everybody's
got to be willing uh to
change uh everybody of course I'm a law
professor and so I can go back to my
Ivory
Tower agreed um I uh I just want to make
sure that we all includ cluding everyone
who testifies agrees so that when we
request the money it's going to take to
fix this that the whole system agrees
that it needs to be fixed and it's not
just this committee trying to fix it the
agrees wheeler thank you Professor shear
and I agree with you chairman Roy that
it is we're not blaming anybody this is
a multifaceted problem and it's a
systemic one that needs to be addressed
um would you say to that point that HB
46 FN fiscal note um the bill put
forward by ranking member Harriet goth
which would have replaced bail
Commissioners with magistrates would
that go anywhere in helping people get
in front of a judge and not uh be held
without trial it would um um you know
I've thought long and hard about that
and I appreciate the expense of that uh
and I appreciate the time it'll take to
implement that um I you know I'm
supportive of that idea I think there
may be other options that might be
cheaper and quicker to implement that
would have the same effect um but that's
as much you know talking with the court
system about what's possible what isn't
possible um you know I I have no
philosophical or ideological problem
with a Magistrate Judge system I I'm
more than willing to
consider um there might be other
possibilities um that would get us at
least for bail purposes uh something
expensive thank you Professor thank you
um is there anyone else here wishing to
testify either from law enforcement or
from the defense bar or the district
attorney anybody see no one I'm going to
ask um representative scitech
got good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Chester Scott
Jordan I'm the prosecutor with the dairy
Police Department uh formerly I
was excuse me I was a police officer
with the town of hker uh back in the L
80s uh early
90s uh then went to law school I was a
prosecutor with the marac county
attorney's office the Hillsboro County
Attorney's office and the Rockingham
County Attorney's Office uh prior to
Department the bill is
proposed is a step in the right
direction in regards to giving all
parties time and that's the issue here
it's the time
to look at the criminal history it's the
time to reach out once again we don't
have a
system where I can print up and the
Commonwealth does Massachusetts
probation parole they prepare a report
for the court and that lists everything
from juvenile offenses up if they're on
probation what is the status of the
probation what the offenses are here I
can have my dispatch run a record
check then I have to review
it and look at the look at the history
look at the sentencing and then I have
to look up to see okay I think he's
still on probation now I make a phone
call to
probation is this guy still on probation
who's a probation
officer so these are all things that
have to be
done when you're calling in a bail
commissioner at 2 in the morning he's
not going to have or she's not going to
have any of this
information what we're asking for in
this bill and and what the bill is
proposed is under these
crimes the person will be held they're
going to come in they're going to get a
fair Hearing in front of a judge in
other words they're going to have a
defense attorney that defense attorney
is going to have time to talk to that
person get their personal history and be
able to argue that intelligently to the
judge the prosecutor is also going to
have the time to do what I just said to
review the record to look at the record
and then investigate make some phone
calls and once again I can present my
case to the judge the defense can
present theirs and the judge can make an
informed
for thank you um if we did have a a Bop
system like that um would it not make it
a lot simpler easier and safer um I mean
you referenced the Board of Probation
Massachusetts the record check I believe
it covers all of mass Juvenile and you
can do a triple I as well um if you had
all that information available to the
officer on the street um the bail
commissioner you as the police
prosecutor You Could See Clearly default
default default I mean it shows
everything all the history and you would
know if they're on probation if they're
on parole um I believe the mass system
if a police officer runs a record check
on a parole the that system notifies the
parole officer that one of his parole Le
has been has been bopped his record
checks been pulled which triggers him to
call his Poley and say what are you
doing or call the police department say
why were you running my guy so I I
continue to go back to I think that
rather
than this right away we need to get that
information system fixed as part of
this what you're looking for is a is a
huge um it is
it's a huge take and it and it's
momentous for a state especially a rural
State like we are um I worked in those
small police departments yeah um I can
tell you that 2 in the morning when I've
got somebody arrested for domestic
violence for just you know assaulting
his wife or and I've taken him into
custody I brought him into the
station first of all I'm the only one at
the station okay I I walked in I
unlocked the front door uh we walked up
onto the porch and then into the PD
because it was a house formally um I've
got the prisoner there I call the bail
commission the bail commissioner comes
down now I've radioed into dispatch
which at that time was at the
county they do not fax me the record
they do not know at that point I'm
dating myself we didn't have email um it
wasn't emailed um so there was no way
for me other than them on the phone
telling me what it is and I'm writing
down as much as I possibly
can even with a connected system I still
think I'm not going to be able to get
that we're talking about small towns
that just don't have that capability or
ability where we do is giving the time
that 24 hours or that 48 depending on
over a weekend or whatever is giving the
person time to be able to get all that
information to be able to come in and as
I say this is not
one-sided this now allows the defense
attorney time to sit down whether it's
going to be 20 minutes a half hour an
hour to get that information before we
have that hearing if we come in in Derry
um where our time is we at nine o'clock
and then it goes from different courts
throughout the day U for the
arraignments so depending on the time
people you know the defense attorney and
the prosecutors will have time to
present that once again so the court has
all the information to make an informed
decision
and that's what that bill this bill will
allow the um the dairy police department
has a leaps terminal I assume correct
I'm sorry the dairy police department
has a leaps terminal I I assume the to
to run the records to do we run yes
we're able to run it at our station and
print them out at our station do you
have any idea about how many departments
in the state are not interconnected or
have not the ability to run a record
check that I could
ballpark
I want to say less than
50%
probably well a lot less I I would
probably say you're down to a quarter
25% is Chief
here
um okay but the majority of police
departments they're not their own
dispatch dispatches are run by the
counties or a bigger community so they
don't th those communities who have the
dispatch those will have centers they
will be able to run those records mhm
but that police officer cannot go back
to the majority of the small towns the
part-time police departments they do not
have the capability of Running Records
out of their office or have a mobile
data terminal in their
vehicle as I say they it depends on on
their
connectivity um and I mean when I was a
police officer granted I'm we're
talking 20 30 years ago now actually 30
years ago now um I had a portable that
was this big and we used it to throw at
people because that's all it was good
for I mean you didn't have any
connection okay all right thank you any
questions for go ahead Stone one of the
questions and I can't recall is breach
of bail a standalone charge in New
Hampshire no it is not it's criminal
contempt that's what we charge criminal
contempt is in your experience to many
officers utilize
that there are well quite frankly there
are departments who charge breach of
bail there is we don't believe that is
under the statute but it is charged uh
criminal contempt we do charge and we do
it on a regular basis yes uh I don't
know
how I I would say it's underutilized
it's it's really not charged U but it is
a criminal contempt of the court and the
problem with that is the criminal
contempt is for the actual court so if
somebody's out on bail say from
Manchester and we stop him in Dairy for
a violation then we know the ify
Manchester because they would have to
file the criminal contempt because it's
you thank you for your testimony thank
you uh representative scitec would you
committee um for the purposes of the
committee representative citex is not a
member of the subcommittee he is here
just to provide information and to help
us because of his experience as a bail
commissioner in as many years in the
house thank you for listening um I'm
us anyone in the back row that can't
hear please feel free to move to the
front row and we'll try and talk a
little bit louder and we just uh the
representative kindly just turned up the
speaker I
believe Okay I uh I think what I want to
do here is to present
a the uh ba a bail commissioner's point
of view I think I can speak for many of
them I know four personally I know a
dozen through our meetings our uh yearly
meetings and I don't think I'm talking
uh want to be careful not to overstate
anything uh I want to uh uh Chief
ferber's gone I did about 10 baales in
Manchester and they really treated me
right so it's nice to know I wish he had
heard that
uh I'm also mildly annoyed Professor
Sher because he said a lot of the things
that I wanted to say in
particular what he talked about and what
I'm going to f argue with uh prosecutor
Jordan about is the front end what the
bail system does what it's intended to
do it is the front end it's not a judge
judging of Innocence or guilt and what
if you follow the dynamic of today's
discussion representative Muse opened
the door and representative gaite piled
right in on conflating the pro the
overwhelming problem of substance misuse
chief chief says we let them out where
do they go what do we do and Professor
sir Sher corrected that to
that's not quite what the that's not at
all what the bail process is about and I
want to focus on the bill from as I said
from a bail commissioner's point of view
even though those problems are so
overwhelming as to almost blunt what
anything we do here because we're
talking about lives too over drugs oh my
god um one of the problems I have is
with what uh uh the chief said and the
prosecutor has said is if someone I
don't know what they're calling it I
don't but if you're out on bail and you
commit a
crime you do not the police don't have
to call any bail commissionary they just
they can send them to in our case
Brentwood in Rockingham County they
don't I don't want to be called if there
are certain other crimes that already
exist that we can't bail we can't bail
murder we can't bail fugitive from
Justice and we can't bail violations of
of a restraining order and I'm that's
perfectly
fine
now why
I'm I have a problem with what the
um uh prosecutor Jordan has talked about
is
this sure the records aren't great we
don't know who's on bail from Manchester
when Derry Picks Them Up I understand
that but whenever I'm bailed do a bail I
get the person's history now I look at
that history and I say it's
largely not
relevant I am there to judge Flight Risk
please don't lose sight of that and
danger to society I don't care what he
did in
2017 I don't care if he has
defaults unless they're excessive when I
talk to PE I you they have the right to
a face to face I talk to I didn't get a
letter well maybe he didn't maybe he's
not telling me the truth I
moved he has a side to his story on a
default I'm not going
to so I I want to tell you from our
point of view from
a uh bail commissioner's point of view
we're we're very we're very careful what
I'm I want to talk about one crime in
the bill and that is the domestic
violence we see lots of them and no
every judge everybody what they're not
they're not going to incarcerate they're
going to say are you going to obey the
criminal bail protective order and if
they feel that they're they're going to
go live with their brother and they're
not going to be go with their wife and
they'll sit for s for a civil standby to
get their underwear so they to work the
next
day everybody does that I've had an I
have my copy books if anybody wants to
see them later the 3,500 Bales I've done
I've done maybe under 10 in my history
fonus domestic violence fonus is he put
his hands on her throat uh he shouldn't
do anything but it isn't that he had her
on the floor choked her to death I
mean it's all done on allegation
now the two in the morning business look
at 2 in the morning I am deciding Flight
Risk not their history not a lot of are
they going to show up for court are they
going to misbehave if I let them out
that's what I'm judging not all these
other things that are useful interesting
that occur farther in the
process I'm going
to so I wanted to talk about that one
aspect I'm going to finish with a bold
statement I don't really want to say
anything further because Professor
sher's idea of felonies and maybe not
all felonies I'm talk that maybe violent
felonies or where you suspect that
there's going to not obey a restraining
order or they're going to continue
Behavior but now we're fine-tuning I
have the his list as he's proposed is
okay but I don't think the Bill's
necessary at all because because bail
commission I heard the chief I don't
believe that we're letting people out on
fonus sexual assault on of course I
haven't done one as a matter in all that
time because look when we aren't sure
and as I said I'm speaking to be I'm
going to say to myself and out loud I'm
not com comfortable here letting this
person go I want the judge to decide
this now I may have my own opinion and I
may be right but the judge is
final not because he's right but because
he's final I'll conclude if I may with
or I think I'm going to conclude I don't
know I scribbled here look the first
couple years I did this I'm very care I
try to be look I I I sometimes talk a
little flip but I try to be careful
about we're dealing with people's loss
of Liberty come on you you just can't be
Cavalier about that but so for the first
couple years I was doing
this and by the way there were very few
almost everything is personal
recognizance there there are very few
cash bails very few hes I spent out
three hours I spent in exitor hospital
because the guy threatened two police
departments I'm going to find out who
arrested me I'm going to kill him or
take him out that the guy's drunk he
would probably be all right but said I
don't want to take any chances so for
three hours I sat there while they tried
to sober and said finally we did a
preventive detention and I went home
because I just didn't want to take any
chances with this situation and I don't
think any bail commissioner is going to
take any chances whether this bill
exists or whether it doesn't exist but
as again I said I have no problem with
Professor sher's thing so I as I said
for two years I tracked no judge ever
changed my bail
one one did I put a cash bail on
somebody I wasn't comfortable with but I
wanted to give them some opportunity
that if they knew this money was at risk
they might behave and the
judge just held them but that that's one
out of I don't know 10 15 that I
actually Chas once you once you finished
your paperwork you God you go home you
don't but I followed them the Superior
Court to see I asked our clerk locally
what happened to Joe Blow and no judge
has and I think I I'm trying to speak
for other I I don't believe I'm out of
turn I don't want to be speaking for
other bail Commissioners they can speak
for themselves but I don't think we're
too big for our britches whether this
bill exists or whether it doesn't exist
so I'm not in favor of the bill I think
if if you had a compromise with
Professor sher's felonies I wish he
hadn't said so many interesting and
useful
things
um all
right representative if if you could I'm
done what is your not the notice that
you've um since be reform in 2018 how
has that affected if at all how you
conduct your job you know the truth is I
tried to do my job irrespective of that
I did not want to be incarcerating
people for lack of as indigent I just
didn't do that I somebody didn't I we
were told look District bail
Commissioners follow the orders of their
District Court Judge we see them once a
year for a conference and we'll get
sometimes get periodic updates okay for
example judge Corby and Salem said don't
ever bail a be state police come with
bees I don't want to bail you but they
that's their tradition so I no Drive
just to put a bail condition but there's
some inconsistencies in the court system
too I'm not bashing anybody but one hand
doesn't always know what the other hand
is doing look I don't live in the Ivory
Tower I live in the booking room okay
and I see this stuff and I try I think
other bail Commissioners try to respect
you're talking about person's personal
Liberty who wants to spend a night in
jail oh it's only 24 hours who who wants
to spend 24 hours in Brentwood jail I I
don't know no thank you for
listening thank you represent you have a
question representative wheeler and then
representative Muse first of all
representative scitec thank you very
much for your testimony I think that was
incredibly helpful um my question has to
do with the topic that we were talking
about earlier today and I want to hear
your opinion maybe you can't give it do
you think that bail Commissioners should
be paid for the work that they do
more so than they already are in some
case as I told you yes yesterday I'm
very lucky it's two out of 10 one out of
10 I miss not so when I did Manchester I
did about 10 there paid for half and I'm
driving from Salem to as a for the team
I I didn't want to let Manchester down
um yes they should be paid I mean if
we're
contemplating what I I think it Prof I
would disagree with Professor Sher about
the magistrate system I think right now
we're paying nothing
mag 10 15 magistrates covering the State
247 really on the on another you're
going to wake up a magistrate an
important person at two in the morning
youve waking up a schnook like me at two
in the morning I'll come in Magistrate's
going to Justice may be short Change
there leave them in jail let
them yes they should be paid I don't
know the mechanism uh but it's just not
maybe not the full I I just don't know
that's that's an important topic perhaps
for another day not this not this I'm
trying to keep it to this bill as much
as I can but I didn't want to not answer
then every time a a baill commissioner
testifies uh we we we do get an educ
um but one of the things that always
strikes me uh in just hearing different
people tell your story their stories and
this is the first time I've I've heard
you tell yours um is it it just always
strikes me how much subjectivity is part
of the process so so for example um you
had said that having having those
electronic records uh that we've been
talking about may not necessarily be
helpful to you
in in making your decision um and and it
sounds like a lot of what you decide is
sort of based on your impression of the
person how they conduct themselves what
they're charged with what the police
what the police say so um what I'm
curious about is uh
is are you is the way that you approach
it is that the model for all B bail
Commissioners or is that the way you
approach it and and what level of
consistency is there uh from bail
commissioner to bail commissioner in New
Hampshire I can definitely tell you I
don't
know uh I believe from I have tried to
be more articulate than others but I
believe that's a kind of cultural aspect
of bail Commissioners I think we have
another one here may two you might ask
them
to comment on my testimony to see how
whether it's at variance with their
experience with their world view you
said also if I may about
subjectivity yes even judges are going
to be have some element of
subjectivity I I do people talk to me I
want to hear what they're to they have
the right to be heard
in my view and many times it's just cut
and dried but there are other times that
I really didn't get the letter I really
please understand that that and look
there was another perhaps irrelevant
story I was called This is everything's
two in the morning it seems but this
really was maybe not that gu the police
this guy has been long record of drugs
drug misuse he was was picked up for
selling we want High cash
bail oh this sounds like a tough bad
customer I come into the police station
look I normally agree with the police
but I come in I I want to talk to this
guy and when to ask for a bail
commissioner what comes out of this cell
but a Sad
Sack
near derel is too strong but just this
is not drug he must I don't know what
the deal was he probably had some wanted
to buy a fix or something from somebody
else or and maybe offered to sell
something so I'm looking this guy did
not warrant you talked about
subjectivity that was my subjectivity
this guy was not worth a felony
Char I can't change the charge that the
police make that's their
business but I can set conditions of
bail and I check no no drug use for your
own good please don't do this and let
him go on personal recognizance this is
not this was
not it was subjective but I believe I
did the right thing furthermore as I
want to repeat you see this judge 20 12
hours later he's going to do what we
do that's a bold statement every one of
you I'm sorry every one of you have the
capacity for making the same kind of
judgment a judge does you're all
thoughtful adults you've read newspapers
you have some in some sense of the law
you make a judgment about people what
does the judge
all thank
you thank you um representative sitech
at this point we're going to take a 30
minute break and a reconvening 12 12:00
when I anticipate us to go probably
another hour today after that when we
get back we're going to actually start
delving into these these um these crimes
and discuss amongst
ourselves um their relevance and how we
can possibly deal with them or other
Alternatives so with that enjoy your
short
lunch
uh we're reconvening a little late I
apologize
um yes a lot of people were very hungry
um at this point I would invite we have
an Alderman here from Manchester I would
invite her to uh come up and address the
to thank you chair o sorry a little loud
in uh committee members uh I'm Christy
canor a concerned Citizen and um an
alderman in Manchester and I'm a victim
of stalking and I definitely don't want
it taken off the list um and I'm highly
concerned about um really helping people
and slowing the process um to get people
to get help that they need and I know as
a victim of um stalking and so forth
from a previous time that it escalates
and it's um it's a known fact that
you're not born a pedophile um there's a
process that it it's a it elevates and
that is my biggest concern is um you
know stopping that process and getting
people the help that they
need thank you um could you tell us in
your put if you could put your Alderman
hat on for a second what are you are
seeing and hearing um in that role as
far as what's happening in Manchester
relative to the criminal um activity and
the the issue surrounding
bail so what we're what we're seeing is
um people are let out right away and
committing more crimes and it's
affecting everyone's livelihood and
businesses and people are concerned
about their safety in Manchester and
there's been like 700 people that have
been re uh arrested a second time um
after they've been out on bail so it's
really affecting um feeling feeling safe
in
Manchester thank you does anyone have
any questions to the
alate seeing none thank you very much
you
okay um uh Mr Knack did you you want to
address a committee I know that I
yesterday and you didn't really want but
ahead
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank kak with the
ACLU of New Hampshire um the handout I
gave you I know you all probably looks
familiar because i' given it to you all
or at least part of it last session and
the reason I'm giving it to you today
and it's about the a bill that's not
spec it's one of the bills before is uh
because uh both uh Professor Sher and um
representative scitec mentioned uh under
existing law the Myriad ways that uh
people can be held um if they are um in
violation if they commit a new offense
Etc and so I just wanted to point
specifically we actually went through
the bails code which is quite long and
pulled uh into just kind of easily
digestible section so the it's like the
third page in uh we go through and list
just the verbatim code section so I
literally just copy pasted so it's word
for word um these are all the ways in
current law that people can be held if
they violate uh if they commit a new
offense also includes I believe I forget
who reference but around restraining
orders and how there's no court judicial
involvement how people can just be um
rearrested and and detained um so all
those are in there and I think as as uh
profess sh mentioned it was quite
telling that um the it sounds like
what's happening in Manchester the fact
that it sounds like it's just a public
education problem that prosecutors don't
know that all these tools exist in
current law um and so I think you know a
really great first step would be to do
education to you know let folks know who
are in the judicial system about what
the current law is what it what it isn't
what they can use um to ensure that we
are not defaulting to just incarcerating
people because people don't know what
they tools they already have um also uh
just really appreciate um the
conversation we've had today about um
the fact that existing law or um um um
um apologize lost my place where is it
oh um the fact that um um sorry I just
want to make sure I'm getting all my
apologize the uh so we had talked about
um um um specific criminal laws and
whether we want to have you know blanket
holds on folks
um uh in whether we want to have a
blanket hold system which sb2 52 and
some of the other bills before this or
we want to have a more individualized
approach and I think you know building
on what uh chairman Roy had talked about
last session and has alluded to today
about trying to create use modern
technology it is 2023 we have all this
ability to take all this data and to get
it to people who need it quickly um and
to prioritize that so that judges or
others making these important decisions
have all that information before them
right away we think is appropriate um
and the reason that we are concerned
about the some of the approaches that
would just say for all these offense
types we're automatically holding you uh
is because you know the facts matter in
these cases and so um and I don't mean
to minimize the harm that some folks
have felt and some of these do accompany
very serious acts that that would result
in these charges we just heard um from
the previous speaker about stalking um
and you know we agree that there are
probably instances where people who are
um charged with stalking may need to be
held pre-trial um but just because
someone is charged with stalking doesn't
mean that it is a horrible fact in each
case and so I actually spoke with a
couple of criminal defense attorneys um
who hear lots of these cases and so
stalking was actually one of the ones
that was flagged for me um they talked
about how it you know conjures up these
horrible images of someone hiding out in
the bushes as like you know what when
you think stalking this is what you
often think about but in their practice
what they usually saw was that it
involved text messages and calls and
often times the it was initiated by the
victim um in those cases and so those
people ended up being released by the
baill commissioner because the baill
commissioner could look at those
specific facts in that specific case and
say this doesn't Merit holding you um
and that's what our current law the
beauty of our current law it allows this
individualized assessment um for the
offense types so um we have other
offenses uh that we heard about um for
example um aggravated fenus sexual
assault um what I heard from talking
with the fence council is often times
again horrific offenses um if they're
true um but what we heard is that um
often times in these cases the charges
are filed years afterward where the
alleged victim and the alleged offender
no longer live together no longer have
contact um and so again the facts in
those cases should be brought before a
bail commissioner or a judge they should
be able to look at that and decide on
that individual case whether or not
someone should be held um and finally I
know we talked about this a lot but it
just came up um from the alderman in
Manchester um is is just kind of what
the facts are around Public Safety post
bail reform and so again in that packet
I handed yall um I we pulled this again
this is directly from the state database
on on um crime so uh Department of
safety's crime stats list from
Manchester for group a crimes which are
the vast majority of offense types all
violent offenses in Manchester crime
since between 2018 and 2020 the most uh
2021 um crime is down for group a 13.9%
arrests are down
33% and for Group B arrests are down
32% um so again the notion that we're
seeing in uptick in off crime is is not
born out by the actual data that the
police have provided to the state um so
happy to answer any questions and really
appreciate um the thoughtfulness that
this committee is approaching this way
thank you um if you if you could um the
the arrests and and crimes being up or
down it really it it doesn't really
necessarily correlate to whether or not
someone's rearrested on on a charge if
they're already out on bail this numbers
just speak to the overall crime which
would not necessarily be impacted either
way by bail it's based on a whole
plethora of social um economic things is
that is that correct I totally agree
with that I think but our concern is
that the the rhetoric that this is
putting forth is that Manchester is this
dangerous PL that these cities have
become dangerous because of baale um and
so I think you know building on that
point you know we've we've heard these
stories um we've seen no specific
evidence that this person was rearrested
was out on bail um and you know when we
started this conversation last session
around the horrific murder in Manchester
um Professor shur actually dug into the
facts in that case and it had nothing to
do with the failure of the bail system
it had to do with the fact that lawyers
did not prosecutors did not use the
tools that they had and it wasn't even
about a bail commissioner it was judges
who had released the the individual I I
don't think I don't think anyone on the
committee um would argue that that
necessary neily that the crime rates are
not down but we are concerned about is
the the the numbers of people who are
are rearrested while they were on bail
is what seems to be driving the
consternation of the um the Manchester
public and that's the problem we have is
with the data once again it's how do we
get it I mean do do you have any way to
to to get that kind of data yeah and
that's we I think there's two issues one
is why we so support your realtime bail
tracking system so that everyone has all
the information in front of them and
there are other states that have done
bail data collection New York state for
one has done bail data collection um and
I think the findings there have been
actually helpful from a bail reform
perspective um so there's definitely
models that we could take I mean they
cost money yeah um but I think you know
we were talking about spending money on
any of these Solutions I think it would
be most appropriate to put the money
into things that will actually get us
the data to make informed decisions I
guess my question was kind of rhetorical
because I don't think there's a way you
could get the data for him right now on
who's been rearrested across the state
on bail and I think one other thing to
lift up as well is and and it would
maybe be helpful to get someone in who
really focuses on this but my
understanding too is there are federal
dollars available for updating court
systems um and so this also could be
done potentially in a way that doesn't
have a fiscal note for the State of New
Hampshire or at least minimize the
fiscal note on a state of New Hampshire
I'd be happy to hear anything about that
so if you have it please send it our way
um does anyone have any questions from
Mr Knack I do I do okay you go ahead you
haven't asked any questions yet no I got
a question uh do you believe bail
bondsman should be
judges the bail bondsmen or bail
Commissioners
yeah I'm sorry which well I you you
talked about varying amounts and
different crimes instead of just saying
a crime you want like a different levels
of a different crime stalking is a
serious thing staring uh is a
progressive crime starts out as one
level it goes to the next level it goes
to the next level just like child
pornography starts off with pitches but
it goes up and up and up so I don't
think you can take different levels of a
crime and have a baales bondsman uh be
responsible for deciding if he's at
level one level two level three I think
all you're doing uh the purpose of the
bailes bond is to protect the safety of
the public so if you have somebody
that's on one of those steps you only
ask them to be detained until the point
that a judge can make a decision where
that person should be released mm
I think that's I'm sorry you agree with
that I think that's the beauty of our
current system is it allows for that if
as we heard from um representative
scitec if a bail commissioner is not
sure then the judge can can look at that
case um so I think that's what we want
to make sure that we have that
individualized versus a blanket we you
know and so also I mean it's I think
it's important to remember that these
charges are just what the police have
brought often times prosecutors once
they get the case File will realize oh
this is way overcharged and will reduce
and so I think it's important that we we
get away from these like just you know
one size fits-all approaches and have
individualized assessments that kind of
brought me to my next question uh you
think the police followup please thank
you so um do you believe the police are
erroneously arresting people or I'm
sorry do you think people are the police
are erroneously arresting people
erroneously yes um I don't believe the
police erroneously I'm not alleging that
the police erroneously arrest people but
you know um I in an earlier job I was
the I ran the Montana Innocence Project
and so we worked to free people who were
wrongfully convicted and if you actually
look at the National Data thousands and
thousands and thousands of people have
been exonerated um because the state got
it wrong and so I think it's really
important to remember that the state is
not always right and so having
individualized versus blanket I think is
better and so the I'm not saying the
police are intentionally doing anything
but everyone police are human everyone
makes mistakes so it sounds like the
system worked I'm sorry sounds like the
system worked if somebody got by
accident get stopped and uh get arrested
then it works no I think I think the the
Innocence case I brought up is how the
system didn't work but for the fact that
there are nonprofits of that have
private dollars raised those people
would still be sitting in jail the state
didn't do anything to get those people
out the state actually fought all those
cases tooth and nail
so it wasn't because the system was
working it was because nonprofits came
together and realized that there was a
fundamental flaw in the way the state
was operating and so we still have
efforts to fix laws that we have decid
you know even in New Hampshire there's
legislation every year around um um um
recording of police interrogations
because we know from innocent work that
police um that that false confessions
happen they don't they happen for Myriad
reasons um that have to do with bi you
know brain science Etc um particularly
with youth um and so instead of actually
you know when when um I guess look at it
this way when a plane crashes what
happens we look at all the facts why did
that plane crash and then we do
everything we can to mitigate the
chances of that ever happening again so
they'll do safety new safety protocols
Etc same when someone dies in a hospital
but when there's a wrongful conviction
that the actual opposite happens there's
no effort by the state to figure out why
did this happen and how can we take
steps immediately to make sure this
never happens again it's only because of
U nonprofit groups that any of those
reforms really ever happen Okay well
we're we're getting far field now so
that's that's all right um
representative uh Stone and then
representative
Muse real quickly on the issue of the
data has anything been given for this
data collection involving the reduction
of police across the state including
Manchester where I'm sure they've had
their staff shortages obviously if you
have less police officers you have less
uh activity and actual work being
produced has that been put into this
factor for these numbers I don't know if
that's been put in but also this has
crimes which are not necessar I mean
those are often Community initiated you
know reported and crimes are also down
substantially and just follow up these
going to be any designation for multiple
Crimes by the same defendant it's the
same methodology AC it's the way it's
been reported to the state so I wouldn't
imagine things like that I assume the
state has always used the same
methodology if they're reporting it the
same way yeah the data that he's given
us is just data that the police reported
to the Department of Justice so um
whatever they got is what we got
representative
Muse thank you um something that uh
Professor Sher said um really did catch
my ear and it's the fact that uh lists
like the ones that we're looking at
become a lot less relevant in if another
part of the law requires people to
actually see a judge within 24 hours uh
which uh which he was saying meets
constitutional requirements in in in a
in a bunch of states and seems to be a
good ongoing
practice
what what it seems to me that we might
be able to do is to craft something that
has a list of some of these crimes and
and essentially what it would become is
a list of offenses where the bail
commissioner doesn't have discretion um
but uh there is a a requirement that if
you're accused of committing one of
these crimes uh that you have to see a
judge within within 24
hours
um I guess what I'm searching for is we
we've spent a lot of time in past
committee sessions kind of reviewing the
list of crimes and trying to pick out
the ones that might touch on misdemeanor
misdemeanors and which ones might be a
little more dangerous than others and
and I'm wondering does that whole
conversation
become a whole lot less relevant if we
have a 24-hour limitation so if we if we
basically shrink that amount of time
maximum amount of time people can be
held without seeing a
judge for all intents and purposes does
a lot of this go away from a
constitutional
perspective I think as I think Professor
Sher spoke about the Constitutional
issues there and that restricts or
minimizes the chance of a concern there
and I would really defer to him on on on
that answer um I think you know two
things from our perspective um you know
I think while we would definitely
support reducing that to 24 hours I
think it's also important to remember
that for someone who's like a shift
worker or a primary caregiver 24 hours
is eternity you can lose your job you
can you know your kids don't have access
um I think what we'd be more um I think
lean towards would be you know under
existing law prosecutors can challenge
any release order they disagree with um
but the very valid argument has been
brought up by those who say that well
that person's then been released and you
know then it's too late so I think you
know one possible Avenue would be to
amend the law to basically allow for you
know if the the the um the state says
you know the bail commissioner releases
the state says for X Y or Z reason
reasons we think you're wrong we think
there's a danger because it's in that
individualized case that's fact specific
that they can they can say we we
actually disagree and we want to appeal
this and that person would be held 24
hours before they got before a judge um
I think that would be potentially more
appropriate because it is fact specific
case specific individual specific and
not just because someone was alleged to
have committed a certain offense type um
I def think you know in all the worlds
that have been brought before this
committee that would be you know I think
the most appropriate from our
perspective but what Professor shur
talked about of having a limited number
would maybe be like a you know a median
you know you know median position um but
yeah I think our our main concern is
what's been brought before this
committee from the Senate which are just
you know whole host of offense types
we're talking thousands of people no
specific Nexus that that person is
actually a danger or a Flight Risk um
and but we're going to hold them we're
going to hold them for a bunch of days
and that's extremely problematic not
only for the individual their families
and also I I provided in the in the
handout also the research shows from a
public safety perspective that actually
safe thank you and and also thank you
for the work um in going through the
statutes and pulling some of this uh
stuff out for us it's going to be very
helpful thank you thank you so much um
is there anyone else here who wasn't
testified wishes to testify
today okay seeing none um at this point
um there's there's several other um
committees I believe that are starting
at 1:00 that some people need to go to
um I think we've taken in a lot of
information today um I think that it
would behoove us all to um take that
think about it and I think um when we
meet again next Thursday we're going to
start with a a a a working a working
document that we can all start to
actually flesh out and and start putting
some some beef on the bone as it were um
and and just to be clear we're going to
be taking um taking some votes but
they're going to be uh nonbinding
they're not going to be the final votes
just so so we can kind of see where we
are and how far apart we are if we are
on certain issues so we can narrow it so
um I would encourage everyone to take
everything we got today all the
testimony we got do your research search
um talk to your constituents see where
you are and when we meet again next week
I'm going to present um an
outline um from at least my perspective
where I think we should start of course
everyone's free and actually I hope will
everyone add to that and um we'll we'll
see where we stand on the issue of the
crimes and people being held um and
hopefully Thursday we can move on after
that Friday to start the next portion of
it does everyone agree with that does
add uh representative
scitech um I may be close to an apology
to uh um prosecutor Jordan I had it
wrong about the breach of bail business
I was told not by him by someone else I
don't have that situation so I was over
my head and I'm sorry I said more than I
should have I'm sorry and I'm sure he's
uh he's
okay um we will um we we'll be moving on
after this um so just to once you've if
you feel like you you're ready for
meeting next Thursday I think after that
we're going to be discussing on Friday
the actual issue of of the bail
Commissioners and their um being paid
and how to handle that so that'll be the
next topic that we'll be taking up on
Friday did you have something you look
like I just have a comment I mean I
think it would be helpful if we had more
victim statements you know I think that
that would um give a a much needed
Viewpoint we I thank you for your
testimony but that was just one and I
think to make a a well-informed choice
we should really be able to hear from
the the victim side as well I I would um
say that um from now until November 3rd
I'm willing to hear anyone who comes
before the committee and wishes to offer
any so if you have someone you know if
someone you'd like to come speak to us
um I'll start we are very uh I'm I'm
running a very open deal here so I want
to hear from everybody all sides of the
argument and then we'll come together
somehow thanks um as a matter of fact I
probably am going to reach out myself to
the domestic violence Coalition and they
will probably have um plenty plenty to
say on that issue um but I'm not
necessarily sure based on what I'm
thinking right now we need it for
Thursday but if you have someone you'd
like to bring that's fine um with that
um no one else has anything to say we're
going to recess until next Thursday at
10:00
a.m.